[Music]
i couldn't believe they all outed all
that blitzed us um
but as soon as i saw it man i was i was
thankful uh
you know and that's why we prepare the
way we do that's why coach teaches the
way he does and
i give coach gruden all the credit in
the world because he has prepared me and
equipped me
to handle those situations whenever we
get those kind of looks to be able to
handle it
accordingly um so you know we just
played the call that the coaches called
and
um you know we just got to execute but
you got to help us out at the same time
just being a
you know better call it that but we were
trying to create pressure
you know he hadn't done well well with
it all game so
you know that's
that's what happened we had a couple
free runners but we didn't get there
is pressure even needed in that
situation all you have to do is
keep stop the play from getting to the
end zone even a short completion would
have been okay
yeah that's what we ended up pressuring
have you talked to greg about since the
game ended about
i just talked to him did he explain his
thought process explain his thought
process
i'd fire him right now i'd have fired
him after the game i'd have gone and
punched him in the stomach i don't
advocate violence i'm just saying that
figuratively
i'd have punched him in the stomach and
told him he's fired
wow that's that's that i mean i i'm i'm
like
i understand the you're fired part i
don't know if you need to punch him in
the stomach or doing anything
i said i said figuratively i don't
advocate violence
i don't know we're not in we're doing
superlatives in a little bit right i
mean
i i don't even i got to do my first one
of the day i don't even know what to say
here it's unbelievable
it's the that was the dumb and dumber
that was the dumbest crap i've ever seen
i don't know what else to say
that makes no sense we're trying to
pressure him
what and we're gonna leave our no name
corner
that nobody knows in the world of
football against a top 20 pick in henry
ruggs
and you're going to take away all
execution and it doesn't matter hey
raiders don't execute
just throw the ball high in the air and
we have better than a 50 50 chance to
catch the ball
so he so you see here with this
defensive line up all the guys
at the line of scrimmage and then here's
the little double move
which even with this stupid defensive
call i want to tell the db
hey sir please just don't bite on the
underneath move
you know but i know he's got to worry a
little because he's on an island and
he's got no help he's got no help so
fast he catches that quick pass and he's
gone he's gone too you're right
it's it's just the worst defensive call
i've ever seen
and let alone mike let's not forget the
play before
they let the raiders get behind them too
right down the middle of the field
and if derek carr threw a better pass
there it was going to be a touchdown
so total catastrophe and i think it
warranted maybe firing him after the
game like you said
i i take no pleasure in this because
well wait a minute i don't know if jets
fans are really upset with the result
most of them are happy they are
to ultimately lose the game and continue
the quest for trevor lawrence but
i still was astounded that greg williams
found employment in the nfl
after how he handled himself in the
bounty scandal when he
submitted an affidavit basically ratting
out jonathan vilma
for the supposed offer of money that was
made prior to the 2009 nfc championship
game i figured he'd be ostracized and
he'd never be welcomed again in the
locker room
i've continuously been proven wrong
because he continuously
finds work and at some point i
reconciled that by saying
he must be one of the great defensive
minds of the modern era
well that argument is now crap because
one of the great defensive minds of the
modern era doesn't do what he did
yesterday
anyone who is remotely familiar with the
madden game
wouldn't have done that yesterday you're
defending one thing in that moment
and that's the goal line you're not
trying to deliver
some message and knock derek carr's
block off that's what it is we are
that's what it is though you're i think
you're right mike i think that's really
what it is and i think that's the
annoying thing about greg williams
it's just ego and like personal emotions
got into the moment like i'm gonna
show john gruden one more time who the
boss is
john gruden i mean he knows greg
williams
and other than last year's matchup when
they played them he's had his way with
greg williams
a lot and torn that torn him apart on
that side of the ball
i just can't believe he would send that
blitz
let alone against john gruden who i just
in my personal experience
has a great feel for greg williams i
mean
we played him a few times and he he was
always all over when he's gonna blitz
when he's gonna do things
uh i just i i don't even know what to
say about it it's just it's unbelievable
and and let's let's put this in the
proper perspective
this isn't the normal run-of-the-mill
miracle in the meadowlands i mean this
is on par with the miracle in the
meadowlands even though the stadium
isn't the exact same
spot but to have a game that should be
over
that's uh that is for all intents and
purposes is
over and to have it turn the way that it
did
that in and of itself is stunning in any
setting
but when you are a team that is getting
down to its last
few chances to avoid joining
the ranks of the 2008 lions and the 2017
browns
as oh and 16 as windless
for a full 16 game season when you have
the chance
to get that win and run out of the
stadium with it
that that's why and you know this is a
question that i have someone was raising
last night as we were talking about it
where's adam gase to overrule
greg williams in that moment right and
say what no no
no put in the put in the the defense
where you got eight guys
whatever they call their version of
eight guys in the end zone
put eight guys in the end zone you put
you practice these things
friday saturday practice this is a big
thing as far as you're going to have a
period where you're going to walk
through
moments like this hail mary situations
how to be on defend it they have no time
on the clock all those type of things
so at some point adam gase was complicit
with it
but yeah this is one where you go please
get in his ear and tell him to get out
of that defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports